cause i'll tell you anything we'll do
anything and we have john here hi john
hi drew
i'm so happy to do this with you thank
you i'm happy to be here thanks for
having me all right what's it gonna be
truth or dare i'm gonna go with the
truth
you can't handle the truth
i've never done that before
all right what's it gonna be okay so my
question is is it ever a good idea to
lie um my significant other who's absent
um he paints and sometimes he asks me if
you know his paintings are to my liking
um and the honest truth is you know
sometimes they're not to my taste
sometimes i think they could be a little
better but my question overall is is it
ever a good idea to lie you know to keep
from hurting someone's feelings i hear
you
i'm gonna say
no
but
i really do like that saying it's not
what you say it's how you say it because
i also think there's a benefit to being
like
i i like it but like it's not my
favorite but i see what you're doing why
don't you take me through the process i
think just a no
and pushing that person away is kind of
cold right maybe you can say like i'm
still trying to kind of get it
why don't you explain it to me here's
why i love not lying first of all don't
lie don't have secrets they kind of go
in the same family to me
but when someone really does like
something
it's so exciting because you know they
haven't bs to you the whole time and you
can actually gauge when something is
genuine versus not so i don't think that
it's worth it to be fraudulent ever but
i don't think that ever has to come with
cruelty
insensitivity or be short and curt there
is a way we can tell our truth that is
kind empathic sensitive and a little
patient
right right
thank you so much dr i appreciate you
and then when you do love something it's
just such a win and it's so exciting
you know believe me i have kids and they
show me all their art and like all their
stuff and sometimes i'm just like i
don't want to tell them i love
everything like what's that going to do
for them i'm not harsh or critical
but you know
what
i think just
gentleness and honesty can go
beautifully hand in hand all right thank
you so much good luck
[Music]
you